[Applause]
chief of the daily wire and host of the
nationally syndicated Westwood one radio
show and podcast the ben shapiro show
ben shapiro i appreciate it i always say
this the conservatives will come on our
show I'm a little jealous of their guts
because they've more guts than the
liberals liberals don't go on
conservative shows they didn't come on
this show sometimes so I appreciate cuz
you know the crowd is not with you I got
that impression yeah and but yeah we
should but we ran let's be civil right
that's the tone of the day and I'm the
fan okay so I'm a fit well let's see if
I'm a fan see each other's fan at the
end admire but I just want to say we
seem to be living in a time of utter
tribalism and I think you and I have a
few things in common besides we were
both uninvited at Berkeley but we've
been coy about our affiliation of like
I've never really wanted to say I was a
Democrat I always voted Democratic but
they disappointed me a lot
you know you've been coy about a you
were Republican you're conservative or I
think right now I'm a Democrat and and
since all the Republicans are now
backing Trump except for the ones who
are leaving but he totally owns that
party now if you're if you're a
conservative aren't you really team
Trump well it depends on on what so what
I've called myself is sometimes Trump
okay there the people said there's never
Trump and there's always from sometimes
Trump meaning that when he does
something that I like I cheer and when
he does something that I hate which
happens then I boo and I'm blowing as
loudly as you are when he does something
that's really bad but listen you're very
upset about the Supreme Court nominee I
am very pleased about the Supreme Court
nominee as a conservative right he's
doing a lot of things that I like in
terms of policy now that doesn't mean
that I am shirring his character because
I think that it is very difficult to
cheer Donald Trump's character nor do I
think it's appropriate well what do you
like okay so I like the tax cuts I like
to tax it hurts me by the way in
California but I like it as a general
policy ladies he's rich
[Laughter]
okay okay but see I don't even know what
the Republican beliefs are I mean you're
a young guy but you certainly remember
two years back when they were beliefs
were completely the opposite of what
they are now when it's free trade they
were giant deficit hawks yep the Tea
Party was all about we're gonna solve
the deficit but they didn't did that
well the Democrats ain't can do it
either so I know but they didn't say
they were right the Tea Party kept said
we have got to get this deficit down
this [ __ ] has ran up a trillion
dollars in six months what what what
about Russia they used to be the enemy
what about free trade I mean how do you
turn on a dime so quickly in a couple of
years I mean obviously it's been very
frustrating to me watch so many
Republicans do exactly that I've been
incredibly critical of Republicans who
have suddenly become fans of Vladimir
Putin or have suddenly become fans of
tariffs I think all of that is idiocy
but again I think that with regard to
judges with regard to taxes with regard
to Middle Eastern policy particularly
Iran in Israel I'm much more of a fan of
President Trump than I certainly would
have been of Hillary Clinton or Barack
Obama and by the way I didn't vote for
president from the last election because
of my concerns about him okay so you
would not vote for a Democrat under any
circumstance or some circumstance I mean
I would say some circumstance but the
Democratic Party would have to stop
being insane meaning that they would
actually have to approach something like
moderation in terms of policy and also
present a face that doesn't look like
people shouting down people at gas
stations or entering restaurants and
trying to throw them out okay well if
you're talking about the civility thing
why don't we start with the Republicans
stop saying lock her up you don't think
that's a worse a bridge winter
just lock her up he talked about locking
co me up he talks about locking
journalists up there's a guy who said
locked tim kaine up how about we stop
the lock them up shouldn't disability
arguments start there before we care
about who gets their entree well it
isn't just about who gets their entree
I'm not gonna make excuses for which is
more important well I think that all of
it is important if you're going to ask
me is bad across the board yes but you
can't be advisors that we're only
imposed okay you're only opposed to
incivility when it's Donald Trump
inclusive but but suddenly Maxine Waters
auntie Maxine because Ben you can't walk
into a Roman tea an elephant in a mouse
and not know which one is bigger but
it's not no offense any Mouse it's two
years really yes threatening to walk six
hundred officers to protect me at
Berkeley yes it's an elephant and an
elephant yes it's an elephant an
elephant a trilobite in 2010 Romney that
he's gonna put y'all back in Chains
about black people this stuff
pre-existed that productive is terrible
didn't come from the president at
Berkeley it came from the vice president
when he was saying Mitt Romney the
cleanest person ever okay was a guy
who's gonna put y'all back and change to
pretend in civility started with Donald
Trump not instability at the level to
which it's at were your time great you
do you really think Donald Trump
respects the rule of law I mean if
somebody no and I think the Constitution
itself is a pretty damn durable document
thank God I've read your tweets like
about Kamala Harris yeah I have some
problems with her too but you would vote
for Trump over her yes tell me why okay
so the reason I'd vote for Trump over
her is because I agree with him a lot
more on policy and I actually believe a
lot of the damage that he has done to
the country in terms of social fabric
has already occurred so I said I didn't
vote for him in 2016 the reason I didn't
vote for him in 2016 is because I feared
the damage he would do to the social
fabric and I also didn't think he was
going to govern conservative because I
didn't see a lot of indicators of that
he's government a lot more conservative
than I thought he was going to and as
far as the damage to the social fabric
if he's already done it I'm not actually
mitigating against the damage to the
social fabric by not voting from in 2020
can I read your here's something where
we sort of agree and then I'll show you
where we don't this is Kamala Harris
tweeted children are our nation's future
we must listen to them about what they
care about and give them a voice in our
government
and you wrote ridiculous I'm with you
their children they don't get a voice
and I think I know what she meant but
it's poorly worded and you wrote
children should not have a voice in our
government their children and you're
right this is where the left drives me
crazy but then you wrote about children
they are also incapable of fully
rational thought
thoroughly uncivilized and completely
driven by immediate emotional response I
can't think of a here more perfect
description of Donald Trump you didn't
see the irony when you wrote that tweet
and described children that way you did
it didn't never entered your mind that
Donald Trump fit that perfectly well I
don't believe that Donald Trump is a
person whose views are leading in in my
in my imagination where the country
ought to go I mean I don't look to
Donald Trump's a thought leader I would
look to a child's thought leader I don't
look to those it's not leader so are you
talking about he's the president says
he's not the thought leader nope
couldn't he have some thought I don't
know Kenny
you tell me I don't know well it seems
like his only thoughts to me are to work
with Vladimir Putin to make Russia great
again and I what I don't understand
Obama was but harsher on Putin you got
in terms of his rhetoric his actions his
armed his armed the people of Ukraine
with deadly weaponry which Obama would
not do 200 Russian soldiers were killed
in Syria by US forces under Donald Trump
not under Barack Obama Barack Obama who
sang to Dmitry Medvedev that he wanted
to bribed him with flexibility in 2012
it Crimea was annexed under Barack Obama
Wow this reminds me of when people
Hitchin just to come on the show and and
try to convince me that Saddam Hussein
was you know a radical Islamist when he
was actually a secularist you have to go
a long way to make that argument I mean
he tweeted yesterday defending Putin
against what our own agency say that he
said Russia says again they did in metal
not election what a lot of crappy stuff
why a lot of wood why have there been 19
indictments and six conviction so far in
the mullah ring Creek why so many
lies about so many meetings with so many
Russians so many attempts to have
back-channel sources what actually think
that Donald Trump collude admitting yes
I do not because I watched that campaign
I don't think that Donald Trump could
collude with his own left foot well I
don't think he did it but his you know
his son did it his the people who and
when the evidence comes out I'm happy to
go for the indictments I'm fine okay
great
criminal activities criminal act but you
see didn't do but wearing his to
ignorance who have done it well
he's not too ignorant he's not too
ignorant to be a criminalist all life
[Applause]
into the Trump Defender here but is he a
doofus or is he an evil genius you gotta
pick one okay actually you don't you
don't have to pick one really look I'm
not saying he's like Hitler here is I
marry bud Hitler was crazy and he was a
genius at what he did which was lie and
manipulate people so you can be both
okay but let's get back to Russia
because I first of all why a nice Jewish
boy like you wants to be on Team treason
I have no idea
dude I'm happy to wait for the Muller
indictments and come down and they
target Trump I'm happy to see them
impeach work that I need to see evidence
but you know that the Republican
Congress we saw it this week with
Rosenstein on the at Congress they are
trying to impeach Rosenstein so they can
get rid of him so they can so we don't
ever see they don't want us ever to see
it they know there's something probably
a thousand things in there that are
incredibly damning okay you don't think
that if they impeach Rosenstein yes some
presento line for you i don't know it's
the final line because there's still
another step that has to happen Rosen
scene has to be replaced by somebody who
then fires Muller so frozen Steen is
fired and Muller is left to his own
devices which is basically by the way
what happened with this investigation
when Comey was fired then I don't see
where the line is Muller is the one who
matters here not report goes to the
Deputy Attorney General and if Trump
puts Scott Baio in that position
he can just throw it in the trash and if
he throws it in the trash or quashes the
muller investigation then yes
impeachment should be on the table Thank
You Ben I want to do it again I
appreciate you coming by I know Friday
night's a tough one for you all right
Ben Shapiro I'll give him the hands